sir uh are you angel I I am how can I
help you today
I don't know if he is still sitting out
there
out then he might be the guy
the guy
called Germans and he's coming here
quite a few times already and it's
bothered me and customers it makes me
very comfortable he said a lot of older
things to me and he likes to grab things
and try and come by on the counter so
kind of want him to trespassed okay yeah
that's not your fault I was arrested
about eight months ago okay back up for
me a little bit okay I was arrested
eight months ago and I spent 18 months
in prison which was not fun
I'm so glad to be out but anyways I'm
suing
the Volusia County Sheriff I'm suing
this is all with my lawyers currently
underway what's your question it's good
for that if I sue the Port Orange to the
police department and they give me 250
000 that's tax free right I have no idea
okay I'll have to talk to my accountant
about that okay I'm here because the
employee in the smoke shop right here
behind me says that even coming in and
out and bothering her and the customer
no no no when she
she told me to be quiet and leave and I
said okay well she says you've been in
and out multiple times and yeah
so hang on let me talk okay let me talk
and it's not a debate or a negotiation
okay you are now trespassing the store
which means you cannot go in there
anymore do you understand that all right
then she'll have to set my stuff outside
there what stuff I have two thousand
dollars worth of merchandise that she's
holding no she said that she runs my
stuff up for you okay go ask her you
mother okay come over here
come on motherfucker Okay you think I
can't do it I know I don't want to do
that
black belts you know you understand your
trespass on the store correct
and watch talking okay and I'll drive
off in your control car okay you
understand your trespass from the store
correct yes
out of my face I'm 12 feet away from
you're not in your face at all
okay
Central second unit go to
come on
you're under arrest
Jesus Christ what's your hand behind
your back right now
sit up okay stand up right here
he's live I sent you a male under arrest
means I'll take this old battery oh this
is another one sweet I'm suing you for a
million I'm 10 million whatever
my lawyer gets a hold of this judge I'll
be out I'll be out in 30 minutes okay
fish car here all right spread your feet
slides spread your feet while you're not
even wider spread your feet
right now you're under arrest from
battery on a law enforcement officer
throwing some at me
so
for lunch yeah well don't do it why
would you throw something at me this
thing just pissed me off oh there you go
you're laughing like
the Sci-Fi Central someone's running
code three to me I don't need that
you're lucky I didn't have my pocket
knife with me
you can write it all in the police
report
that's the thing I wanted to do is get
arrested and go back to jail then you
shouldn't have thrown some of the police
officer you're an idiot for doing that
well I'll never do it again
that's not true